first we start with our top story
tonight this is a serious topic the
Biden Administration now has completely
dissolved our Southern border it no
longer exists in this country whether
his feeble mind realizes this or not Joe
Biden is now not only violating the law
and violating his oath to the
Constitution he's now officially
endangering the National Security of
this country he is costing every single
American costing States and the country
billions and billions and billions of
dollars completely abdicating his role
as commander-in-chief sworn to uphold
the law and our Constitution and frankly
insulting every single one of us by
lying to us the borders secure no it's
not instead of a southern border well we
now have a giant processing center
welcome Joe Biden and by the way anyone
everyone in the world who wants to come
over and enjoy let's see free housing
free clothing free food free health care
free education Transportation guess what
you get it all compliments of you the
U.S taxpayer but the real draw for so
many so-called Asylum Seekers is the tax
free U.S dollar now it's made by working
under the table and this cash then is
largely sent back home to loved ones in
other countries that's why most of these
illegal immigrants happen to be single
men in spite of what liberals have been
telling us for years by and large
they're not really seeking Asylum
they're trying to make a buck I don't
blame them for that but they got to be
do it legally now today a brand new
record 10 000 illegal immigrant
Crossings this one single day mostly
single men yet again so what did our
wanted White House Press Secretary uh
the ever so articulate and genius
Jean-Pierre have to say about this new
record let's take a look
thanks green so what do you call it here
at the White House when 10 000 people
illegally cross the border in a single
day so what do you call it Peter when
GOP puts forth a wait no no no no no no
no no I'm answering okay we're gonna
answer me no no no no no no no we're
moving on the background
no no I tried to answer Peter I tried to
answer the question you stopped me let's
go
oh thanks for answering uh Peter will
join us in a moment he'll respond to all
this but uh I'll tell you what she is
calling it just in a normal day in Joe
Biden's America the standard ebb and
flow quote of illegal immigration listen
to this answer we have worked very hard
the president have worked very very hard
to implement a strategy when it comes to
the border that is Humane safe and has
orderly enforcement how many people
coming into this country illegally is
enough President Biden that
say that last one how many people come
how many people illegally coming into
the United States is enough for
president
enough for what 5.9 million people have
been encountered illegally I know the
numbers but enough for what and not just
to stop the Flop as I mentioned this is
a problem that's been around for some
time now for decades a broken system and
so we have taken actions we have taken
multiple actions but again this happens
it Ebbs and flows that's what we see at
the border for different trends for
different reasons what the point that
I'm making and the point that I think
you all uh have some of you have
reported on this is a president that has
taken historic action on an issue on a
system that has been broken for some
time in three years it'll be around
eight million illegal immigrants that
Joe Biden has led into this country and
he's got another year to go after that
uh and that means more illegal
immigrants have poured into this country
get this then the entire population of
the state of Colorado or the state of
Wisconsin and if it helps Joe to
understand that's six times the
population of his state of Delaware now
this just simply has to end people have
got to be turned away starting
immediately and people here illegally
they've got to be sent home if you do
not respect our borders our laws and the
sovereignty of our great country you
should not be rewarded for entering this
country illegally so Kareem Jean-Pierre
is lying just like Biden has been lying
and majorcus has been lying but from the
very beginning of this crisis well we've
heard nothing but lies they even tried
to claim reportedly that our borders
secure over and over and over again no
it's not take a look
sounds to most folks like a crisis well
look it's way down now we've now gotten
control precisely that the border is
closed nor could I have been clearer and
continue to be so which is the border is
closed the United States will continue
to enforce our laws and secure our
border the Border we are working to make
the Border more secure you're confident
this border is secure
we have
a secure border in that that is a
priority for Any Nation including ours
in our Administration we agree that the
border is secure the border is not
closed the border is not secure stop
lying to us why tell such blatant lies
the truth is even more insane it is an
unacceptable National Disgrace and a
national security threat not only is the
Biden Administration working hard to
remove barriers to Illegal immigration
including physical obstacles protections
like Trump's staff Mexico policy they're
also facilitating get this the arrival
of these illegals including free flights
free cell phones and free everything
else and soon they're going to be
handing out official Joe Biden you and
United States of America ID cards as a
reward to everyone that refuses to obey
our laws but that's not all get this buy
an Administration they are now also
helping illegal immigrants fly from
their country
directly into our country without ever
having to even cross the southern border
now according to a report for the center
for immigration studies published by the
Washington examiner quote listen to this
the Biden Administration has Unleashed a
new program to boost illegal immigration
that allows immigrants to fly directly
from their home towns and their country
to a U.S city of their choice now they
have an app our country's put out a Joe
Biden app it's based on a program that
can be accessed anywhere in the world
and so far over 210 000 illegal
immigrants have entered the country this
way they don't even have to come to the
Border we'll just fly them in for free
Joe's going to fly him in you see what
is happening here this is not a crisis
or a problem for the Biden
Administration that's why they say well
no the borders closed we don't we don't
have a crisis the borders closed and
secure Administration their goal this is
their way it's all very intentional they
are encouraging they are aiding and
abetting and the law breaking and this
Mass illegal uh immigration into our
country they just don't want it to look
bad at the border so we'll just fly him
indirectly whatever country they want to
come from now tonight we can speculate
about the motives but we can all see
what the consequences are billions and
billions of your dollars down the drain
resources that are already stressed is
stretched in in big cities small towns
all across the country we have 33
trillion dollars in debt and a border
that is only controlled by the violent
Mexican cartels they charge admission
into the United States they're making a
fortune and at the same time these
cartels they're using the mass
immigration process as a distraction
because they flood the zone so all of
the you know eligible available border
patrol agents they're stretched thin and
they're focused on the one area where
the biggest flood of illegal immigrants
are coming in and meanwhile the rest of
the border is free for their illegal
activity to bring in drugs opioids
fentanyl human trafficking as a result
what a hundred thousand Americans each
year are you know being killed by these
deadly drugs all you know an all-time
record high for this country and the
Biden Administration says no it's closed
we're secure that's not secure they
don't care this is their plan this is
their policy they don't care about the
drugs they don't care about the human
toll on Americans they don't care about
the human trafficking they don't care
about the criminals coming across
undetected and maybe worst of all is
there a zero vetting of all of these
millions and millions of illegal
immigrants no background checks on
whether they have radical associations
we've caught tons of people on a
terrorist watch list you know they're
caught regularly but even worse are the
terror cells that Joe Biden has allowed
into the country what are they doing
they're going to plot scheme and plan
another 911 style attack it is now
almost inevitable that happens he will
have blood on his hands American blood
this is insanity now if they don't care
about you the American people they
certainly don't care about the risks
posed to human beings on the other side
of the Border just today look at this
the bodies of two people including a
three-year-old boy were fished out of
the Rio Grande but remember according to
Karine Jean-Pierre this just happens
it's only the quote ebb and flow of
illegal immigration hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else